what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again with another
demonstrator video and in my last
relationship video about inosuke and aoi
i said i discussed mitsuri and iguro if
that one got over 6500 likes and as i'm
writing this that video has over 14 000
likes so it's about time to discuss the
awesome hashira couple since there isn't
really another big or obvious
demonstrator couple to discuss make sure
to drop a comment for what video topic
you'd like me to discuss next in the
comments and yes i will discuss how
strong upper moon 2 doma is soon so
everyone waiting for that i'm on it if
you do enjoy seeing these demonstrator
videos on the channel i want to keep
them coming you know what to do share on
the hashtag within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is hashtag energy and
passing his demon king of pop energy so
choose wisely i know a lot of you want
demon king of pop energy as well so you
know do whatever you want if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next demonstrator video
or episode to drop feel free to check
out my huge and growing demonstrator
playlist that includes videos on all the
hashira demon moons tangerine kano's
relationship zenito nezuko's
relationship and much more link to that
is in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all obana iguru is the snake or
serpent hashira depending on the
translation you use and i'll probably
use both of them interchangeably just so
you know he's 21 years old and when the
mangaka ranked each hoshida's physical
strength via how well they do in an arm
wrestling contest yigura ranked below
everyone except shinobu who we know is
not even physically strong enough to cut
off a demon's head this means that yes
iguro is physically weaker than the 19
year old love hashira mitsuri he also
eats way less being able to go three
days without eating and he tends to give
off a much darker vibe compared to
mitsuri's bright and warm one it's
definitely a situation where opposites
attract and in this case there's clearly
some subversion of traditional gender
norms as well as i mentioned iguro is
physically weaker not saying he's a
weaker swordsman but just that he's
physically weaker and we were even told
that he'd rank lower than the 14 year
old muichiro and the nalhashra tanjiro
in arm wrestling another interesting
detail is that mitsuri is taller than
iguro mitsuri is 167 centimeters or
about five feet and six inches and iguro
is 162 centimeters or about five feet
and four inches so we covered some
fundamental and superficial stuff about
these two but now let's jump into the
manga and see how the love story evolved
over time although they already know
each other by this point igura fully
debuts during chapter 45 of the manga
it's the hashira meeting and in contrast
to the forgiving mitsuri igura wants to
punish kyu for breaking core rules and
protecting the demon nezuko by the way
coolness points for the fact that he's
just chilling on the tree while the
others are all standing on the ground i
gotta say one of the reasons i love this
ship so much is because iguru is
possibly my favorite hashira and i just
love his character and mitsuri if i have
to choose is probably my best girl as
well but back to igura he also has one
of the most unique looks with his
differently colored eyes bandages over
his mouth and a living snake for a
necklace but anyways back to the story
mitsuri responds to igura's words with a
heart popping up over her head in the
manga she thinks to herself and i quote
as usual iguru is as coolly menacing as
a snake he's reliable which is nice and
quote she's blushing as well when she's
thinking this in most cases it would be
heavily implied that she's in love with
him but it's not so clear with the love
hashira since she also blushes thinking
of tanjiro giyu sunemi shinobu and so on
the love hashira blushes and has hearts
coming from her character in multiple
cases which i suppose goes with the
whole being the love hashira thing thus
she clearly has a positive view of iguro
but in the beginning it doesn't seem to
be especially significant because she
has such positive views about the others
as well after all she's a very positive
person iguro doesn't make it clear that
he's into mitsuri here either he more so
makes it clear that he's pretty ruthless
in contrast to mitsuri who aside from
gilu has the most compassion for tundra
and nezuko when sanemy wants to test
nezuko iguro is the one who reminds him
that it won't work in the light and he
has to go into the shade or she won't
come out his personality and behavior
are quickly established as being very
different from mitsuris whereas mitsuri
felt pity for tanjuro and even thought
he was cute iguro is the one who quickly
elbows him to the ground when tundra
fails to show respect in front of their
leader and thus we don't find out much
about these two except that iguro is one
of the many people she likes and he can
be pretty cruel and ruthless in contrast
to mitsuri who is so positive and
compassionate we do see something that
they do have in common during chapter 66
they're both affected by rngoku's
passing if you didn't know then goku
trained mitsuri and she was actually
learning flame breathing before she
developed her own style she raises her
hand to her mouth when she hears of the
former mentor's passing deeply moved we
don't see igor's expression but he does
say he can't believe it so he's clearly
not indifferent to the news either we
next see iguru after the defeat of upper
moon 6. he shows up to the scene and at
first says he's impressed but that
initial bit of praise is quickly
complicated when he asks what tengen's
going to do about losing his hand and
eye in a fight with mir upper six again
not much kindness and empathy shown here
instead of being glad tengan's alive he
sort of insults him for losing limbs to
a low upper moon and then immediately
asks how long will it take him to
recover and who will replace him in the
meantime when tangent tells him he plans
to retire now igoro thinks it's
ridiculous and even says he won't allow
it since they lost rengoku they
desperately need a slayer of tangent's
caliber even wounded so he has to fight
until he dies what the mangaka is doing
well here by depicting igor as such a
ruthless unfeeling dude is that she's
preparing to move us when we finally
find out how much iguru does care about
mitsuri we all know it's all the more
impactful when a seeming jerk shows off
his soft side just ask bulma next let's
fast forward to chapter 101 just to see
how much mitsuru eats not only does she
eat more than iguro as mentioned she
eats way more than tanjiro it looks like
when goku eats and after she finishes
all those dishes and tundra says
impressive she says she didn't eat that
much tonight implying she usually eats
much more it's after this meal that
tundra asks mitsuri why she joined the
demonstra core in blushing she answers
to find a man to marry she explains that
it's good for a girl to find someone
stronger than herself someone to protect
her now i know that some of you might be
thinking that iguro is not physically
stronger than mitsuri which is correct
but even if he's not physically stronger
he is the stronger swordsman and
performs better in battle and we'll see
that later so as of now we know that the
love hashtag is looking for a dude who
is stronger than her and who can protect
her thus her options for ships are
pretty much limited to male hashira
since she's so strong to begin with and
we can probably cross out tangent who is
weaker than her at this point and also
has three wives already and maybe even
sanami the wind hashira because mitsuri
remarks to tanjiru that both shinozugawa
brothers scare her since rengoku
tragically died that only leaves giu
iguro gyome and muichiro as possible
options and keep in mind muichiro is
five years younger than mitsuri at only
14 years old so really we're looking at
three options either way igoro is
quickly becoming more and more of an
option as we narrow down the
possibilities using her own criteria
what's also relevant for the purposes of
this video is mitsuri's backstory during
chapter 123. we get a flashback of
pretty much how she was told she can't
get married because of how funny her
hair color is and that's something you
gotta actually know about mitsuri
because as anime watchers i think most
of us would just assume her hair is
normal anime hair but in the world of
demons there it's made clear that this
is not the case two years ago she was 17
years old and her marriage arrangements
fell through we're also told in this
flashback that she's the eightfold girl
meaning her muscle density is eight
times that of a normal person so if her
actual muscle power was reflected in her
body's appearance she'd look very jacked
indeed at only 13 months old mitsuri
lifted a rock that weighed 33 pounds her
mother was shocked for the first time
ever upon seeing this it's also repeated
that she had a big appetite and could
eat get this more than three sumo
wrestlers combined none of these
qualities were viewed as ladylike and
appropriate for a would-be wife so
mitsuri felt like she had to hide her
true self she dyed her hair black ate so
little that she always felt faint and
pretended to be weak despite the fact
that she had superhuman strength finally
a man was ready to marry this version of
her but she didn't feel right about it
she wondered if there is a place where
she could be herself if there was a man
out there who would accept her for her
true self clearly mitsuri wasn't looking
for a lot just someone who would like
her for her and she realized that no
dude weaker than her could probably do
that based on her previous experiences
which is why she started searching for
someone stronger significantly on the
cover page of chapter 124 we get a huge
image of mitsuri smiling and blushing
while she eats iguru is the one sitting
beside her staring at her with gentle
eyes we're not given the complete
context here but one can imagine that
they are close and that they enjoy each
other's company and that igura probably
offered to pay to be a gentleman even
though he probably barely ate that last
one might just be my interpretation but
the point is we'd already had her
possible ships narrowed down to about
three people at this point and now this
image of them together pretty much
narrows it down further to igura
specifically and the clues about their
feelings for each other don't stop there
not even close as more of mitsuri's
backstory is revealed we find out that
instead of getting married as someone
she's not she found the demonstra core
where her true self was seen as a
blessing not a curse furthermore she
reveals that iguru gave her the long
green striped socks that she wears the
panel is adorable igoro can't even look
her in the eye as he gives them and we
see two hearts in midair between them
and at this point when we realize a big
part of her image came from iguro this
whole time it seems obvious that iguro
and mitsu are into each other and are
probably going to end up together if any
to hashira will the question is why
aren't they already together and that
will be answered when we get to igoro's
backstory eventually for now let's fast
forward to after mitsuri's fight with
upper moon 4. the hashra meetup muichiro
beat upper moon 5 and mitsuri helped
beat upper moon 4. sunemi comments that
he's jealous that he never got to fight
an upper moon but iguro actually shows
concern he asks how mitsuri and muichiro
are and it's so sweet to see mitsuri's
face light up as she says i'm much
better thanks mitsuri blushes and sweats
as she answers igoro and if that weren't
enough she even thinks to herself that i
quote oh he's worried about me end quote
this is clearly one of the more focused
on ships already and there will be even
more significant moments that solidify
the ship however you can already tell
that there are more clues that these two
will end up together than there were
that inosuke and aoi would by this point
even though these guys get less screen
time than inosuke there's also a funny
part here where they ask mitsuri and
muichiro to explain how they unlock
their demonstrator marks mitsuri tries
to explain but is absolutely horrible at
it and everyone is struck by how bad her
explanation was igoro's reaction is
emphasized he even does a facepalm she
proceeds to apologize profusely for
being terrible at explaining but it was
cute seeing how affected igor was by her
embarrassing situation i feel like the
usually stoic dude wouldn't be so
visibly affected by such a situation
unless he cared deeply about mitsuri the
hashira go on to run their own training
courses and when tundra gets to iguro's
course we get even more clues as to how
much iguru cares about mitsuri we're
told that the two hashira exchange
letters and when igoro sees tundra he
gets very angry uncharacteristically so
he mentions how mitsuri told him about
tanjiro and how they had quite a lot of
fun in training tundra senses that igura
totally hates him from the start but it
seems more like jealousy because tenjio
got so close to his precious mitsuri
this hypothesis is confirmed when after
tundra passes the training iguru
specifically warns him not to get too
friendly with mitsui i love iguro's
expression when he says this his veins
are even popping up on his face so far
they've done a really good job of slowly
but surely sprinkling in clues about how
igura feels about mitsuri and about how
mitsuri feels about iguro mitsuri
obviously never gets so overprotective
and jealous over igura but he does fit
her criteria and it's clear she likes
spending time with him treasures his
gifts to the point where she wears the
socks he gave her every day and even
blushes and sweats at the thought that
he's concerned about her and that's not
even to mention that they exchange
letters all the time at this point all
we're waiting for is the confession of
love or an explanation as to why we
haven't gotten it yet and now we fast
forward to the demonstrators versus
muzon fight part one both iguru and
mitsuri are present with the others and
probably not a coincidence they're often
shown close to each other in the panels
and as a result of their close proximity
to each other they get warped together
we get a sweet moment where some demon
extras show up and igor handles them
real quick saying and i quote stay away
from kanroji we know that mitsuri wanted
exactly this someone to protect her and
it's not a surprise that she brightens
up and blushes when she sees this she
even thinks to herself iguru is great
it's so cute seeing these two together
igor asks if she's hurt she says no he
says let's go and she says okay with
three hearts floating in her speech
bubble and i don't think we've ever seen
her blush so hard based on this she's
clearly got the feels for igoro 2 and if
you still think these two aren't perfect
for each other then i just don't get you
but moving on the two go on to fight
current upper moon 4 nakime and it's not
really a fight in the conventional sense
nakime gives them a lot of trouble but
she doesn't threaten their lives that
much in other words she's not especially
strong but her blood demon art is very
tricky and annoying and makes her hard
to hit as she's shifting the dimension
around them during this fight mitsuri
gets hasty and igoro saves her by
grabbing her while she's falling in
midair iguro is so sweet when he tells
her in a nice way as long as they don't
know their opponent's abilities they
should watch closely think hard and
proceed calmly the last thing he wants
is for mitsuri to die you know if tundra
made the exact same mistake he'd be way
harsher on him later when tundra is
confronting muzon with giu we see an
image of iguro and mitsuri having been
defeated now it's pretty obvious that
there is something fishy here since
igoro was built up big time so having
him just lose off screen would be kind
of ridiculous if mitsuri helped beat the
old upper 4 it's hard to believe that
her and the stronger igura couldn't take
down the new replacement still for a
second this looks horrible it looks like
our snake romeo and lovely juliet the
couple whose romantic relationship has
probably been emphasized the most in the
whole series might have died without
ever confessing their love to each other
in a straightforward way luckily as we
find out this was genjutsu via yushiro
aka an illusion mitsuri shows up soon
enough to muzon shock as does iguro who
helps save tanjiro if you pay close
attention you'll also see that mitsuri
is all beat up after the fight with
nakime while iguro doesn't have a
scratch or speck of dirt on him another
sign of his advanced skills as the fight
against the hashira and muzon goes on
it's mitsuri who starts falling behind
as iguru mentions that he can no longer
shield himejima probably one of the
biggest unintentional flexes in a line
in the entire series mitsuri is thinking
that she can't see muzon at all she's
relying on intuition and luck to dodge
and she knows she'll be the first one to
fall so while iguro has been protecting
others in addition to himself mitsuri
has been having trouble just keeping
herself alive and she proves to be
correct she's the one who gets seriously
damaged by muzon first a portion of her
face and arm are taken off and of course
iguro's worried reaction is the first
one we're shown after this happens once
again iguru prioritizes her and is the
one who takes her to safety he leaves
her with people who can tend to her
wounds while mitsui is saying she can
still fight igura though in a touching
moment says no she's done enough iguro
then leaves and a waterfall of tears
fall down mitsuru's face as she begs
iguro not to get himself killed she also
wishes that igoro and her had met under
normal circumstances and we see an image
of them in civilian clothing strolling
in nature like this was a jane austen
novel and not a demon slaying manga
however igura whose mouth is finally
exposed to reveal a joker-like snake
scar says such a life was impossible for
him we finally see why he didn't make a
move earlier he says and i quote unless
i die and get a different body in which
this filthy blood does not flow i have
no right to be with you and quote he
clearly has an inferiority complex which
is kind of funny because mitsuri
obviously has one as well they both
don't think they're good enough even
though each would be ecstatic to have
the other as a romantic partner iguru
goes on to explain that he belongs to
corrupt bloodline that has killed to
line its own pockets with stolen money
they have inhabited mansions feasted and
lived in unnecessary luxury they were a
shameless avaricious ostentatious and
ugly clan then we jump into his
backstory i will just say first that it
frustrates me when characters think like
this that they can't be happy and have
to pay for the sins of their bloodline
even if they themselves did nothing
wrong i'm not saying it's bad
storytelling and i'm sure there are
people who blame themselves like igoro
does but i just love igoro so much that
it's hard for me to see him being so
hard on himself but that tangent aside
his backstory is that he was born into a
family of many girls and it had been
370 years since the last boy was born
since birth igura was confined in a cell
the woman fawned over him and brought
him rich foods there was so much food
and the smell of it made him nauseous in
part this probably explains why he
doesn't eat much anymore at night he'd
hear something creepy and massive
crawling around when he turned 12 he
found out that this was a serpent demon
lady this female demon was worshiped
like a god by the family the family
lived off the riches of the people this
demon killed in order to keep her happy
the family offered their newborns to her
as a sacrifice the demon took a special
interest in iguru who was a rare boy
with unusual eyes as a result she
allowed him to grow to a more satisfying
size before she would eat him at her
meeting with the 12 year old igura she
determined that she'd let him live a
little longer and even had his mouth cut
to more closely match her own and
obviously the jokers oh yeah and she
drank the blood that came from this
process very messed up stuff now back in
the cell igor was understandably
thinking about escaping and surviving
before he gets eaten by a gross lady
demon i think i speak for all of us when
i say good job that's what you're
supposed to do in that situation he used
a stolen hairpin and began scratching
away at the cell bars this is the
closest demonstrator gets to a prison
break right here at this time he was
very scared they'd find out and the only
creature he could trust was the snake
kaburamaru who he still has to this day
around his neck i like the fact that
they didn't just demonize snakes in
general here and showed how yeah this
snake lady is evil but kaburamaru who is
a literal snake is igor's best friend
there isn't something inherently bad
about snake or serpent stuff and that's
reflected in the fact that iguru himself
goes on to become the serpent hashira
anyways eventually he makes his escape
with his snake best friend the lady
demon finds him but before she can kill
him the flame hashtag saves him this is
a cool detail because it seems to be
then goku's father here before he fell
off the rails and became a pessimistic
drunk even though he eventually fell off
it's nice to know that the good deeds he
performed when he was a hashira
continued to have a huge impact in the
present after all without him we
wouldn't have iguro who is insanely
valuable as one of the strongest and
most skilled hashira the flame hashira
brought igura together with his only
surviving cousin but she rejected him
and this part infuriates me too because
i feel so much for iguro she blames her
snake boy for killing everyone why
because 50 people died as a result of
him running away they would have lived
if he just played the role of a happy
sacrifice to this demon even though on
some level iguro knew her words were
unjustified her words still pained him
and got to him he had thought about what
happened to them but decided to flee
anyway because he wanted to live he
started viewing himself as corrupt just
like his filthy family his sins were
deep in his view so he could not live a
normal life with no other outlet he
turned his rage on demons he risked his
life for others and felt as if he had in
some way become a slightly better person
nevertheless the decaying hands of 50
people whose eyes shone with reproach
continued to claw at him and hold him
back he wanted and planned to die
defeating muzon and prayed that the deed
would purify his filthy blood then if he
were reborn as a human being in a
peaceful world without demons he would
tell mitsuri of his feelings for her so
that's why he didn't confess his
feelings up to this point he felt like
he was too corrupt and the only way he
may feel okay doing it was if he died
defeating the strongest demon and was
reincarnated like bro you did nothing
wrong i want to tell him his family put
him in that situation and was ready to
sacrifice him so him just trying to
survive is completely understandable and
justifiable those women that died were
guilty of not only benefiting from the
demon killing others but also for not
helping iguro and countless other babies
partnering up with a demon has its risks
and having the demon suddenly destroy
you all is one of the risks that comes
with the territory so part of me
desperately wishes that iguru didn't
feel like this but don't worry we will
get our happy ending and it'll be
perfect iguru goes on to be absolutely
amazing in the fight against muzon but
you can check out my how strong is igoro
video if you want to know the exact
details about that since that's not
really the focus here long story short
iguru fulfills his wish he puts up a
valiant effort against muzon awakening
the demonstrator mark turning his blade
red and gaining access to the
transparent world in the process it's
touching to see how he thinks about him
and mitsuri as a team and thinks that he
needs to hang in there and fight harder
to make up for mitsuri's absence and he
really does make up for her absence
since he is the first hashira to get up
after muzon wrecks them and saves
tanjiro even though he's lost his vision
by this point and has to rely on
kaburamaru by the way how awesome is the
snake if you agree with me drop a
hashtag i love kaburamaru in the
comments after they defeat muzon we see
iguro holding mitsuri they are both
dying from their wounds mitsuri
apologizes for not being much use in
this fight but igoro tells her to please
not say that he reminds her of the first
time they met igoro says she was such a
normal girl when they met that she saved
him she got excited over the smallest
things and her laughter was like belle's
ringing it was definitely love at first
sight for iguru yiguro enjoyed talking
to her and was happy feeling like a
normal boy while doing so he says her
bottomless cheerfulness and kindness
saved many people so she should be very
proud igoro would never let anyone say
otherwise and this is the part where i
was probably bawling the first time i
was reading it and even now my eyes are
getting kind of watery not gonna lie
mitsuri cries too saying she's so happy
and she cares about iguro so much this
is her side of the confession right here
she says meals always tasted best with
him because he looked at her with so
much affection she says please igoro if
we're reborn and we're humans can i be
your bride and now even this usually
stoic dude is crying and he says yes of
course if you will agree to have me it's
one of if not the absolute sweetest
moment in demon slayer he continues
saying this time i will make you happy
and protect you so you don't die and now
knowing how they both feel about each
other they both pass away in each
other's embrace probably happier than
they've ever been in their lives now if
you don't know what happens you might be
like gosen how's that a happy ending
they both died right when they were
supposed to start their lives as an
official couple but remember what keeps
being mentioned in their relationship
arc the idea of reincarnation and being
together in that peaceful world that
comes to fruition in chapter 205 of the
manga and it's my favorite part of that
chapter in this chapter we get a huge
time skip and we see the descendants of
those who survived the fight with muzon
and the reincarnations of those who lost
their lives fighting him we see the
reincarnated versions of mitsuri and
igoro on page 10 and it is so fulfilling
and satisfying the perfect happy ending
that they hoped for and that i really
really hoped for they owned a family
diner together they offer huge servings
a mitsuri touch and has snake decor and
igura touch we even find out that iguro
just like in his old life got jealous
when yoshiteru zenitsu and nezuko's
descendant wouldn't stop staring at
mitsuri's chest so igoro now a cook
threw a knife at him the throne knife
aside though we can imagine that they
are a very happy married couple and
mitsuri's reincarnation just like in her
past life completely lights up the room
with her smile and that is it for
possibly the last addition to the
demonstrator couple breakdowns i hope
you enjoyed it let me know if you ship
or skip this couple in the comments but
if you do skip them just know that
you're objectively wrong this romantic
pairing had the most outwardly romantic
moments in the series while the others
seemed to stay more in the background
until the end i feel like this one was
very much in the foreground for these
characters if that makes sense it never
felt like an afterthought absolutely
loved them both individually and loved
them both together and after doing this
video i gotta say this is at least tied
for my favorite couple and maybe even my
favorite couple and demon slayer
although since it is the freshest one in
my mind i may be a little biased right
now anyways let me know your favorite
couple of the ones i covered below
tundra and khanna zenitsu and nezuko
if you did enjoy this video and want to
keep the demonstrator videos coming you
know what to do
chill the hashido within and smash that
like button with no mercy with
zero mercy remember smashing that like
button is hashtag energy and passing is
demon king of pop energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstra videos and updates that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next demonstrator video or episode
to drop feel free to check out my huge
and growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos about all the hashira
demon moons tundra and kano's
relationship zainto and this
relationship and much more link to that
is in the description and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you